so how was it okay for critics to
continually go after the vice-president
over his Christian faith joining us with
his reaction daily wire contributor and
author of the unholy trinity the left's
assault on life marriage and gender Matt
Walsh Matt thanks for joining us this
morning so why is attacking a Christian
faith still inside the bounds well first
of all I just wish that if you're going
to attack the Christian faith maybe
learn like one or two things about it
because that's not in the Christian
faith that anything is permissible in
the pursuit of a higher good that's
exactly the opposite of the Christian
faith ends justify the means that's an
atheist secularist point of view that's
not the Christian point of view but the
second thing is there's this really this
really stupid idea that if you're that
if you're a conservative Christian
politician your faith for some reason
isn't supposed to motivate your policy
positions like we're supposed to be
robots you know is separating our faith
from our policy but they never say that
if you're an atheist politician they
would never say well that's not supposed
to motivate it and even if you're a
Christian politician and you're you know
fake Christian Democrat and you say well
my faith says that we need to have open
borders and you know reduce carbon
emissions they'll they'll celebrate that
and they'll welcome that it's only when
you take certain positions that all of a
sudden they're very worried about your
Christian your Christian faith because
it's just bigotry against Christianity
and you know there's something
specifically about pencils when I talk
to Democrats a lot of them say you know
what we really don't want to impeach
President Trump because because pence is
worse than Trump I mean they really have
a special animus for our vice president
they do it on the left there's nothing
worse at all than being a conservative
Christian there's nothing worse than
being a social conservative and if
you're a conservative Christian then
that's gonna be associated with that and
you see yeah they obviously they hate
Trump and they criticize Trump for petty
things sometimes but with with Mike
Pence I mean they criticized him for not
wanting to go on lunch dates with other
women who aren't his wife so I mean
they'll go after Mike Pence for
literally anything because when it comes
down to it I think on the Left the the
primary motivating thing for modern
leftist is that they will they hate
Western civilization as it has
historically stood and they see
correctly that Christianity has been the
driving force for Western civilization
historically point was a vice president
was asked about those comments this is
what he said
anytime I'm criticized for my belief in
Jesus Christ I've I just breathe a
prayer of praise this is a nation of
faith and so I will continue to stand
for the things that that we believe in I
bet those comments scare that CNN
contributor even more yeah that's that's
very terrifying I mean listen to that
Christian supremacist yes
no but Mike Pence he does a great job of
he responds to this as a Christian and
and I think it responds to it in a way
that's very disarming because it shows
how ridiculous it is to be afraid of
Christians when he's saying when he's
very gentle about anything
look I'll pray for these people and and
that's it that's that's the Christian
response and I think it's great well
done Matt Walsh thanks to your time
appreciate it thank you Matt thank you